we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here is a
caller who well i'll just let her say it
i don't need to tell you too much about
it take a listen hey david it just
watched the video about Trump tweeting
over fifty two times in one hour
and was very much reminded of my
mother-in-law before she was officially
diagnosed with dementia would all family
members up to one hundred times a day
leaving voicemails are talking to them
because she literally forgot that she
had called us and part of me in this
absolutely worried and this would be
horrible but it really reminds me of
that and he makes me think that this
could possibly be a sign of dementia
that he's not remembering all these
tweets that he's given within an hour
and it just really reminds me of that
thanks so much yeah so I mean of course
you know I'm not qualified to say
anything about a dementia diagnosis but
what you're talking about with memory is
interesting and there's a couple things
I would I would put out there number one
there are times when reporters quote
Trump's own tweets to him and he
certainly doesn't seem to remember them
his answer doesn't indicate he actually
remembers the content of the tweet but
that just may be how Trump answers
questions okay that's one thing there
are reports from people inside the White
House not authorized to speak about this
that say Trump doesn't remember he just
doesn't remember he doesn't remember
conversations he's had with people he
essentially arguing that one of the
explanations that maybe is not getting
enough attention when Trump appears to
be lying or saying that he didn't say
something that he's on record saying is
that he genuinely has no memory of it so
this is not the first time that such an
allegation has been made on today's
bonus show very exciting I am going to
give you a prepping update I have a
number here in in my home studio I have
received via the mail a number of
elements of prepping that I've ordered
some which are
obviously beneficial sum which I have
questions about so I'm going to talk
about that a little bit on today's bonus
show we will also talk about 2,000
former Department of Justice and FBI
officials who are calling on William
Barr to resign for his handling of the
Michael Flynn case we will talk about
murder Hornets so-called and we will
also talk about the Supreme Court
appearing as though they are going to
give religious employers a pretty
broad-based ability to discriminate all
of those stories and more on today's
bonus show get instant access by signing
up at join pakman.com or by making a
pledge of at least 5 bucks a month at
patreon.com slash david pakman show
we'll see you on the bonus show or on
the live streams or on tomorrow's
program appreciate you joining me today